bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo dédiée à
strangers thing saison 4 et notamment sa
partie 2 et sa fin personnellement je
trouve que l'ensemble de la saison 4 a
été vraiment grandiose la série a
clairement décoller nous avons enfin des
réponses à des questions qui restaient
en suspens depuis des années et du coup
bah voilà on a enfin une véritable
direction pour la saison 5 le grand
final je préfère vous le dire dès
maintenant mais bien évidemment la vidéo
va spoil l'entièreté de strangers thing
saison 4 volumes 2 donc voilà vous êtes
prévenus cette vidéo va me permettre de
partager avec vous mes pensées et mes
idées concernant la suite et la fin de
la série donc prenez cette vidéo comme
une sorte de rendez vous d'après série
histoire de partager tous ensemble
d'échangé concernant la fin de strangers
singh saison 4 peut-être que mes idées
seront fausse peut-être que mes idées
seront bonnes voilà c'est pas le but
principal le but c'est d'échanger et ce
dans la bienveillance avec vous alors
écoutez si vous êtes prêt je vous
propose que l'on commence à les l'escaut
bon comme je vous disais j'ai trouvé la
saison 4 grandiose la mise en scène
était incroyable la bo était folle comme
à son habitude v cna est un méchant qui
hype de fou mais voilà bien évidemment
il ya quelques petites faiblesses rien
n'est jamais parfait et j'aurais aimé
plus d'éclaircissements sur certains
points notamment sur toute la partie
avec hopper et le démon gorgon avec les
démos dogues en russie en fait comme je
vous disais nous avons désormais une
direction pour la saison 5 toutes les
intrigues secondaires se sont plus ou
moins terminée avec la saison 4 c'est à
dire que tous les personnages principaux
sont réunis hopper est revenue à hawkins
heleven aussi tout le monde s'est
retrouvé pour confronter vesna dans un
combat final et voilà mais si je
souhaite revenir sur le cas de hopper
avec la russie c'est qu'il ya une raison
en fait c'est lié au mind flyers vesna
alias one alias henry nous a dévoilé
qu'il est à l'origine du mind flyers
quand il a parcouru le bright dawn il a
fait face à la chose qui lui a permis de
transcender son enveloppe humaine
c'est l'essence du mind flyers grâce à
ça il a pu step up en terme de pouvoir
créer une sorte de mémoire génétique
collective et du coup d'être en symbiose
avec le psy down pour tout contrôler et
revenir à hawkins sauf que le truc
intéressant c'est qu'en saison 2 le mind
flyers a pris le contrôle de will en lui
injectant une partie de son essence au
fil des péripéties joyce avec les autres
vont réussir a sorti la partie du mind
flyers qui reposait en will néanmoins
nous avons appris par le biais de la
saison 3 que cette partie existait
toujours en fait rappelez vous cette
partie de l'essence du mannequin fire
s'est échappé et s'est caché dans
l'aciérie breeam bornes sauf que vu que
le portail de la saison 2 a été refermé
par heleven et bien la partie de
l'essence humaine fire a perdu la
connexion avec loeb saïda et s'est
dissipée mais les russes se sont
introduits dans hawkins avec le centre
commercial starcraft et ont réussi à
ouvrir un nouveau portail ce qui a
permis à la partie de l'essence du mind
flyers qui se reposait en will et qui
s'est échappé à se réveiller et à
redevenir actif du coup cette partie de
l'essence a utilisé des rats pour se
reformer puis infecté billy et des
humains pour se construire à un corps
physique et c'est là au moins j'aurais
aimé plus d'éclaircissement car dans la
saison 4 nous sommes témoins que les
russes sont en possession de la partie
de l'essence du mind flyers rien ne nous
a été montré concernant tout ça mais
voilà en tout cas les russes étaient en
possession de cette essence jusqu'à
copper s'échappe de la prison bien
évidemment tout a mal tourné et
l'essence a été libéré et s'est infiltré
dans le corps des démos dogues pour leur
redonner vie d'après ce que l'on
comprend de la discussion entre le russe
et murray hopper joyce et murray vont
finalement tuer tous les démos dog et le
démo borgo sauf que ces lacs cet
intrigant car désormais hawkins paru des
d4 portail ouvert par baic n'a possède
un gigantesque portail et par le biais
de la saison 2 et 3 où l'essence du
maine flyers avaient été vaincues entre
guillemets en quelque sorte et bien ce
dernier est de nouveau là à chaque fois
malgré la mort de son corps physique
notamment donc ce qui veut dire que
cette partie de l'essence devrait
toujours existé voilà je ne sais pas si
j'ai vraiment réussi à me faire
comprendre surtout ça met du coup pour
moi c'est un élément qui devrait revenir
dans la saison 5 à part si pour les
frères de faire cette partie de
l'essence a vraiment été dissoutes entre
guillemets par joyce murray et aux peurs
mais bon voilà bref on va laisser ça de
côté pour le moment bon du coup il va
quand même bien falloir que nous
parlions un petit peu de vekhnaïa
leeuwen et will carpien évidemment comme
tout le monde le pense ils seront
forcément centraux dans cette saison 5
déjà par rapport avec na son origin
story permet de répondre à son retour
dans la saison 5 effectivement henry
n'est pas mort il a bien souffert à la
fin de la saison mais voilà il est
toujours là le truc c'est qu'on nous a
appris que ce dernier avait transcendé
son enveloppe humaine par le biais de
l'oeuf side out et qui l'a énormément
step up grâce à ça donc cela
expliquerait l'arrivée de l'orage à la
fin de la saison vesna reviendrai mais
par le biais du mind flyers nous
retrouvons tous les codes instaurée en
saison de la présence de l'orage avec
des éclairs rouge et cetera et cetera
grâce au fait qu'il a dépassé sa
condition humaine et par le biais de la
mémoire collective v cnapd agir sous
plusieurs formes et tous ne nous a pas
encore été dévoilé par rapport à ça ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que
désormais one hell le psy down en
quelque sorte donc tout ce qui est relié
à l'aube siders fait partie devait cna
dans ma vision des choses étant donné
que le mind flyers et l antagoniste
principal de la saison 2 et 3 eh bien je
pense qu'il pourrait le faire revenir
pour la première partie de la saison 5
et après du coup
vec nappe pourrait utiliser d'autres
moyens comme on nous l'a montré en
saison 3 par exemple par exemple vesna
pourrait se servir du corps des dix pour
communiquer et agir sur terre depuis
l'aube saïda et comme il nous l'a
démontré de part son plan il souhaite
amener une armée on ne sait pas vraiment
s'il opte side harnes est composé de
dizaines de centaines ou de milliers de
démo gorgon et des mots dogues mais
comme il a été montré par le biais de la
saison 2 et la 3 v cna peut contaminer
des gens par le biais du mind flyers
pour les contrôler donc henry pourrait
se former une armée par le biais du mind
flyers dans la réalité de la terre comme
il l'avait fait avec billy en soi et
créer du coût des surhumains et là du
coup nous pouvons partir loin dans la
théorie l analyse puisque nous pourrions
avoir à un délire où tous les gens
affectés par v cna doivent mourir qu'à
regarder l'existence d'une personne
infectée par baic n'a serait un moyen
pour lui de revenir encore une fois et
vu que c'est la dernière saison bas cela
signifie la fin définitive de ce dernier
donc voilà et là du coup nous pouvons
rebondir sur will wheels est sûre il
aura une importance capitale dans la
saison 5 il a été l'élément central de
la première et deuxième saison est dans
la symbolique ce serait fort de terminer
avec lui mais le truc c'est que je pense
que l'on ne nous a pas encore tout dit
concernant will pour le moment ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que l'histoire de
will est vraiment unique ce dernier a
passé une semaine entière dans l'aube
saïda où il a été confronté est manipulé
par le mind flyers donc vesna et encore
aujourd'hui ce dernier ressent sa
présence comme s'il était toujours
connecté à lui et c'est ça qui est
intriguant
car par exemple max de par son
expérience avec v cna nous a affirmé
qu'elle se sentait toujours marqué par
l'empreinte de vesna qu'elle était
toujours maudite en quelque sorte et
c'est ce qui lui a permis de jouer
là-bas dans la fin de saison alors
maintenant si on relativise par rapport
à wil dont l'histoire avec le psy dawn
est allé beaucoup plus loin que celle de
max et bien ce n'est pas anodin si ce
dernier ressent toujours autant avec n'a
personnellement je le comprends comme ça
mais je pense que à partir du moment où
on a été marqués en quelque sorte par v
cnal my fire ou le bayern j'ai
l'impression qu'on leur est en quelque
sorte indéfiniment après cela reste ma
vision mais je le comprend notamment
comme ça par rapport à wil d'ailleurs
will not is an soit son rôle pour la
saison 5 puisque de par sa conversation
avec mike nous comprenons que ce dernier
va potentiellement reprendre son rôle
qu'il avait en saison 2 c'est à dire
celui d' espions will est le seul
personnage qui sait ce qu'il se passe
dans la tête devait cna il est le seul à
savoir véritablement son fonctionnement
et comment ils agi parce qu'il a fait
partie de la mémoire collective
vous pourriez me dire qu'elle heaven et
96 aussi en soi mais perso je trouve que
c'est différent nancy a vu ce que vesna
voulais lui montrer et heleven connaît
bien avec n'a il est vrai mais elle
connaît surtout henry de par son passé
avec lui et le fait qu'ils possèdent
tous deux des pouvoirs et qu'ils ont été
malmenés par breno will lui a fait
partie devait cna pendant une certaine
durée est ce que vous voyez ce que je
veux dire et d'ailleurs chose qui pour
moi permet de prouver à quel point will
est connecté profondément avec na sais
que personnellement je pense
véritablement aujourd'hui que le fait
que l'obs et daouda est bloqué en 1983
et plus précisément le 6 novembre le
jour où il a disparu c'est parce que par
le biais de la mémoire collective et du
fait que will est la première personne à
avoir été connectées à l'aube saïda le
mind flyers et du couvent et cna est
bien le monde a été transposée dans
l'aube side aoun en fonction de la
vision de will après par rapport à la
saison 3 les nombreuses infectés qui ont
été sous l'emprise du mind flyers l'aube
side aoun avec la mémoire collective
c'est peut-être servi de la mémoire des
gens infectés pour préciser un peu plus
la transposition de hawkins dans l'obs
aydan mais en tout cas il y encore des
secrets par rapport à wil déjà tout
simplement du fait que barbara qui était
la deuxième victime de l'ops a down a
été tué
par le démon gorgon alors que will a été
quant à lui capturés et asservi d'hôtes
pour le mind flyers afin d'amener son
retour bien et maintenant parlons un
petit peu d'eleven heleven est
l'équivalente d'henri les deux
personnages étaient différents des
autres enfants il était supérieur comme
le disait one sauf qu'avec le temps ils
ont eu chacun une histoire différente et
c'est très important de le souligner
henry qui s'est retournée contre les
hommes et l'humanité a dû survivre dans
l'aube saïda où une seule et a évolué en
quelque chose d'encore plus monstrueux
et dangereux de l'autre côté heleven
quant à elle a fait la rencontre de mike
d autres enfants d'opr de joyce elle a
connu l'amour la reconnaissance bref
elle a évolué entouré d'amis et d'une
famille et c'est très important de le
notifier car c'est pour moi l'essence du
combat final de la saison 5 owen nous a
confirmé que la première fois qu'il a vu
la photo des victimes devaient cna il a
tout de suite reconnu le style de one il
a tout de suite compris qu'il était de
retour et du coup sa réaction a été de
revenir vers heleven pour lui demander
son aide et de par là c'est nous les
deux personnages ont une conversation
dans le restaurant owen nous a affirmé
qu'elle even n'était pas du tout le
monstre et qu'au contraire elle était le
seul espoir du monde qu'il était même
prêt à parier sa vie qu'elle était une
bonne personne et c'est là où pour moi
la symbolique est ultra forte car nous
avons deux personnages surpuissant sauf
que l'un agit pour le mal entre
guillemets pour vulgariser et l'autre
agi pour le bien l'un veut amener la
mort entre guillemets tandis que l'autre
veut conserver la vie sauf que je pense
qu'avec n'a à quelques pas d'avs ans par
rapport à elven car ce dernier a tout
fait pour s'élever et comprendre toute
la mesure de son pouvoir parce qu'il
était bloqué dans l'aube saïda et
souhaitait se venger toute l'attention
de one était focalisé sur son retour et
ses pouvoirs alors qu heleven c'est un
peu dispersé car elle tentait de vivre
une vie normale
entouré de ses amis et de sa famille et
c'est là où nous pouvons ramener brenner
qui dans le fond avait raison heleven
n'est pas encore prête tout simplement
car elle n'a pas encore conscience de
toute l'étendue de son pouvoir c'est la
thématique forte pour moi de la première
partie de la saison 4 one et heleven
sont aussi puissants l'un que l'autre et
leeuwen a même pris le dessus sur roanne
sauf que henry a pris le temps de
comprendre l'étendue de son pouvoir
alors qu'elle even pas encore et par le
biais de la mort de max heleven au pied
du mur a fait un pas en avant concernant
ses pouvoirs elle est capable de faire
encore plus et c'est dans la pire des
situations qu elle en prend conscience
elle a réussi à ramener max à la vie
alors que ces dernières venaient de
mourir depuis une minute entière étant
donné qu'elle haven est l'équivalent de
one en quelque sorte ils sont aussi
puissants l'un que l'autre eh bien je me
dis qu'il haven est capable des mêmes
choses que one c'est à dire qu'henry
s'est émancipée des règles que lui
impose l'univers pour faire ses propres
règles et au final il a pris le contrôle
de l'ops down donc heleven pourrait
faire de même et c'est ce qui nous a été
teasé par la survie de max heleven s'est
émancipée des règles pour redonner la
vie à max et la sauver et du coup elle
pourrait faire d'autres choses par le
biais de l'obs aydan possiblement en
fait comme nous l'a expliqué henry il
n'est pas obligé de suivre les règles
imposées par le monde il peut créer ses
propres règles il est quelqu'un de
supérieur et du coup si on transpose par
rapport à elven eh bien c'est la même
chose heleven peut ne pas suivre les
règles imposées par le monde et c'est ce
qu'elle a fait max aurait dû mourir
c'est une règle qui fait partie de la
vie mais heleven s'y est opposée elle a
contré la mort est l'une des règles
fondamentales de l'univers en ramenant
son ami à la vie et cela tisse pour moi
un début d'évolution pour heleven quand
elle prendra conscience qu'elles
possèdent les mêmes capacités que one
nous pourrons avoir un véritable combat
si on relativise cela veut dire qu'elle
even peut-elle aussi se servir de leur
taille down elle peut se servir du mind
flyers pour agir elle peut utiliser la
mémoire collective et c'est là que nous
pouvons ramener la partie de l'essence
du mind flyers qui s'est échappé heleven
pourrait s'en servir pour confronter
avec n'a elle pourrait retourner contre
lui tout ce qu'il a bâti
dans tous les cas c'est ma vision des
choses après tout nous sommes totalement
libres d'imaginer ce que l'on veut pour
la suite et la fin de strangers tings
tout simplement car rien n'a encore été
véritablement établie pour la fin de
l'histoire pour tout vous dire les
frères de feurs n'ont même pas encore
écrit le script et le scénario de la
saison 5 pour le moment là au moment où
je vous parle donc tout est possible
a vous de me partager en commentaire
votre vision des choses je suis très
curieux de savoir comment vous imaginez
la fin de stranger tings et son grand
final de par les récentes déclarations
nous pourrions nous attendre à une
sortie pour milieu 2024 concernant la
dernière saison nous savons aussi qu'il
y aura des spin off concernant la série
après strangers things mais bon à voir
ce que ça nous proposera étant donné que
normalement il n'y aura plus vesna plus
d'obstacle da on est plus d'eleven
normalement je sais pas on verra quoi je
souhaitais quand même rajouter un petit
mot concernant le personnage de brenda
je trouve que son retour dans la saison
4 était vraiment grandiose je me
souviens que l'acteur était plutôt
mécontents du traitement de son
personnage dans la première saison
ce que je peux comprendre en vrai il
symbolisait juste un méchant
scientifique sans background et c est là
avec la saison quel je trouve qu'ils
l'ont vraiment approfondi et sincèrement
sa mort était vraiment impactante enfin
voila je suis très content de la saison
4 même s'il ya des petites faiblesses
évidemment rien n'est parfait mais
sincèrement strangers singh c'est
vraiment un truc de fou je kiffe trop
cette série
et j'ai vraiment hâte de la saison 5 on
en parle depuis la saison 2 je crois et
comptez sur moi pour être là pour la
dernière saison il ya même des chances
qu'on fasse des petits théorie dans les
semaines à venir les mois qui viennent
concernant strangers things mais bon
c'est à vous de me dire si cela vous
intéresse je peux comprendre que le
sujet ne vous intéresse plus donc voilà
à vous de me dire si vous voulez des
théories on pourrait creuser un peu le
sujet et cetera dans les jours à venir a
vous de me dire sur ce j'espère que la
vidéo vous aura plu évidemment n'oubliez
pas le petit pouce bleus qui soutient
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
pour ne pas louper les prochaines vidéos
et voilà écoutez c'était dargaud rock
que le line rares soit avec vous allez
ciao tout le monde
[Musique]